what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with dr strange damnation i was
gonna cover strange academy but then i
realized that we were supposed to cover
doctor strange academy on sunday but a
lot's happened over the course of the
last two to three weeks so uh i was a
little distracted
but we are back to uh we're back to our
normal self so here's the thing right in
the first video that we did when we did
doctor strange damnation essentially
doctor strange has resurrected or at
least brought back the city of las vegas
after it was destroyed during the events
of secret empire but because of the fact
that las vegas is the city of sin and
because of the fact that it had
basically just been been sent directly
to hell when it was destroyed
mephisto sees control of it and so when
doctor strange resurrected or brought
back las vegas he accidentally brought
mephisto with him and as you guys know
from our coverage of like the fearlords
like nightmare and the chaos lords like
dormammu and the hell lords like
mephisto that usually whenever they show
up and they have a way to enter earth
they don't usually stop at one place
right they do everything they can to
conquer the whole realm and the reality
is mephisto's been trying to find a way
to conquer earth forever and so doctor
strange just gave him a way to do it so
what this led to was of course the
avengers assembling but being overtaken
by mephisto while he didn't even fight
him that's the thing mephisto didn't
even fight the avengers like literally
he was standing in his penthouse and
just seized control of the avengers and
turned them into ghost riders just the
kind of level of power that we're
talking about here i didn't even have to
like fight them directly he could be
like a little ways away drinking a cup
of coffee and defeat them right it's
just it's kind of nuts and so in
response to this wong who of course was
the only person that could really do
anything right doctor strange is kind of
was really in a bargain with mephisto
now so he can't really act directly uh
the result of this is that wong
basically started assembling the
midnight suns now the first person he
visits here is blade of course blade's
in the middle of fighting vampires and
you know once the whole fight's done
he's like hey man we need your help
and that's kind of the thing at that
point he switches over to elsa
bloodstone now we'll talk about elsa
bloodstone here in a little bit because
let me tell you that man a lot of the
characters in marvel comics are kind of
cool elsa bloodstone is legit she
doesn't take anybody's [ __ ] and she's
one of the coolest characters out there
that just never really gets any
attention fingers crossed we see her in
the future of the mcu because she's just
amazing but the next thing of course we
switch over to danny rand who's just
kind of practicing his martial arts and
talking to juan you know because when
you're danny rand you just practice
martial arts you practice ways to stay
relevant uh and then of course we get to
moon knight who is who's also brought in
and then we get to jericho drum now the
funny thing about this is jericho drum
as far as people that could offer any
legitimate assistance here he's only one
of two right the reality here is that
jericho drum is also known as brother
voodoo and then eventually doctor voodoo
a little uh little tidbit here for you
guys when doctor strange basically lost
his role as the sorcerer supreme due to
his refusal to help the vashanti in
their war that when he was stripped of
that mantle it went to jericho drum and
jericho drum became the new sorcerer
supreme now of course eventually steven
strange got the title back but his
powers were reduced which is the way
that marvel kind of took him away from
being like the old school ultra powerful
doctor strange who could basically do
anything he wanted to and was a walking
talking plot device uh to making him
just a guy who could do some cool stuff
but could also still be defeated and so
really ever since then and even the
years leading up to his appearance
jericho drama has always kind of been
like a background doctor strange right
like a substitute doctor strange if for
whatever reason steven's incapacitated
jericho drum usually steps up but at
that point we switch over to the final
person being brought in by uh by wong as
part of the midnight suns and that
person is johnny blaze's ghost rider now
the funny thing is like when he shows up
here basically ghost riders filling up
his gas tank which is weird why does a
ghost rider need gas and then in turn uh
he buys some scratch-offs
and i just felt like that needed to be
said because it's just kind of how
johnny blaze is right he's just like
he's like 26 on 12 and two of those
scratchers
but the other thing is that there's a
girl buried in an unmarked grave a
little girl that's buried in a mark
grave and basically nobody helped her
right and and when something happened to
her whatever that happened to be so of
course johnny blaze is going to go there
he's basically going to torment the
town's people destroy them and then send
their souls to hell now of course wong
basically talks him out of it and simply
saying like mephisto has returned to
earth now here's the reason why johnny
blaze blows that off and it's important
to understand the relationship between
the two to even understand one the power
of johnny blaze and two why he's doing
this so the power of johnny blaze is
such that as the ghost rider this dude's
broken like ghost rider is so
overpowered he basically has a portion
of mephisto's power so that's why it's
not uncommon to see someone like ghost
rider just wreck world breaker hulk or
to see someone like ghost rider
potentially even go toe to toe with a
person like galactus the most powerful
item or really the most powerful aspect
of ghost rider is his pen and stare
right like if he makes you endure the
pen and stare so long as you're not
somebody like punisher who doesn't feel
bad for what they do or whatever it is
you will experience a physical pain that
is the representation and the
manifestation of all the pain you've
ever caused anybody over the course of
your life right it's just absolute
torment and that's only a fraction of
what you will endure when you get sent
to health but of course johnny blaise
was turned into the ghost rider by
mephisto right and so the result of this
is that he harbors a particular hatred
for mephisto one because of what
mephisto stands for and two because of
the bargain that was struck when he
entered into it unwittingly and was
ultimately transformed into the ghost
rider now of course once the group is
brought together there's some legitimate
questions that are being asked here
right the first question that's really
asked at least by johnny blaise is hey
man so like the last time doctor strange
is doing his thing he basically hung out
with the century why don't we just have
the century do it and of course the
response of wong is one the century
hates doctor strange and two it's not a
good idea now the reason why this is not
a good idea here is because if the
century were to be brought in and then
face off against mephisto mephisto would
probably pull out the void personality
and then subjugate it and then in turn
you would literally have the
personification of death and destruction
across the universe under the control of
mephisto let me get okay here's some
perspective when the void first
manifested in marvel comics in the
mainline universe right not in the old
paul jenkins j lee what if story from
like it was unofficially called a
wedding story but like that alternate
reality story i mean like when brian
michael bendis brought the sentry into
the to the main marvel universe through
new avengers when the void personality
manifested and this is just the void by
himself a full contingent of the
avengers and the x-men and the fantastic
four they could do nothing to stop this
guy they could do absolutely nothing to
stop the void right so imagine that
person whose power is amplified by the
power of mephisto and then just sit on a
warpath right like it would be the end
times
now at that point like elsa bloodstone
kind of chimes in and it's like okay
look like here's the other question i
have though i mean like if the avengers
were defeated by mephisto and he didn't
even have to do anything what's the
point of us being here right like a
handful of us some martial arts guy some
guy who just doesn't know which
personality is his actual personality
some useless vampire hunter and then
blade's like what like hold on repeat
that again useless and elsa bloodstone's
like look dude i'm a monster hunter by
trade because she is right i mean she
literally has like she's the daughter of
ulysses bloodstone so she's half human
and basically half like super powerful
and like she's immune to vampires and
things like that but she's like like i
literally hunt hunt like monsters by
trade and i've i never see vampires like
they're the least prevalent thing and
and even then knowing the monster world
as i know it they're the least important
thing right like what you are doing is
basically busting shoplifters and then
like trumping yourself up
as some guy who's protecting the
national interests of america right like
come on man you hunt vampires right and
and like at that point blade's like
whatever man just be happy you don't see
any vampires you're welcome for that by
the way and it's like okay whatever
right so
that's why i love oh you know elsa
bloodstone elsa bloodstone man she does
not give a damn do she will just she'll
call it like it is man in a lot of ways
she's like the internet right there's no
filter she just says what she thinks
right the internet and children are very
similar in that regard and so ultimately
wong basically finishes it all off and
says look i called all of you here for a
reason right like for the most part
you're either dead damned or you carry
darkness with you and none of you are
without sin and he says i chose you
because you are our only hope of
fighting mephisto without adding to his
ranks and if i'm being completely honest
i chose you because if you get turned i
believe it within my power to bring you
down before you hurt others right so
it's like even if mephisto takes you i
could beat you so like you know i mean
it's just it's the thing now the funny
thing about this is that wong actually
has an ace up his sleeve and we'll find
out what that is but it's just it's one
of the most genius maneuvers and writing
like even when donnie kate's in the
early days and because this is like one
of donnie kate's early stories right him
and nick spencer basically wrote
damnation even when he was like an early
writer you could tell this guy was just
destined for greatness as a comic book
writer right he's absolutely amazing so
here's the thing like at that point
wong's like okay we're leaving in 30
minutes everybody get ready now once
they arrive at the vegas strip i mean
the battle kind of goes the way you
would expect it to
[Music]
not even lie right this is i mean
looking at this roster you're kind of
like okay so like this is gonna go one
of two ways like either everybody's
gonna get wrecked or like someone
somewhere is going to just happen to do
the right thing at the right time and
basically save the deck and so it's kind
of like okay basically it's the
former blade gets hit with the hammer of
thor no one seems to be able to lift it
off a blade so he's just stuck in place
right literally with a hole burning in
his chest but the crazy thing is that in
the middle of all the like in the middle
of this battle right like where you have
all these guys were facing off a cement
truck just comes flying out of nowhere
and it's like where did this even come
from only to find out that it's actually
been riley the scarlet spider who's got
ak-47s strapped to his back using his
classic costume or close to his classic
costume and was probably one of the most
awesome depictions of his character ever
right one of the most awesome things and
literally he's like okay that's not
gonna keep him down for very long you
guys are all gonna be safe with me and
everybody's just kind of like i mean but
like really though he's like what man i
live here right like i live in las
vegas that's always kind of cool right
because of course everybody starts
popping back up again but in the midst
of this when they're trying to make
their escape you end up finding out that
basically dr strange's soul has been
taken like he's been captured by
mephisto basically he's a servant of
mephisto now so essentially like this is
uh this is a huge deal right because now
it's the power of doctor strange that's
basically available to mephisto that can
be used against these guys and that's
when things start getting bonkers
because at that point one you have
people trying to get the hammer off of
blade because at that point it looks
like he's dead literally it's a flaming
hammer it's a hell hammer which is
really cool but like it's a hell hammer
of thor right being wielded by jane
foster nobody seems to be able to get it
off and then you get this crazy weird
moment i mean you have like wong facing
off against doctor strange but everybody
always forgets about bats but everybody
always forgets about the ghost dog like
literally uh doctor strange goes to use
the pen and stare on wong and if he
pulls it off it'll destroy him right i
mean it won't necessarily destroy his
physical form but it'll break his mind
and then he'll kill him and then he'll
send wong to help and wang is really the
linchpin here right if wang falls this
battle's over and the reality is that
with the avengers being conquered as
fast as they were assuming that you even
have anybody that can go toe-to-toe with
mephisto uh which frankly rich was
probably the best bet for that that
anybody outside of him would likely be
conquered and at this point time
remember franklin's a kid right and he
still has mental blocks in place you'd
have to remove those and then just cross
your fingers and hope he doesn't destroy
all of creation in the process and then
ultimately mephisto would conquer the
world and that would be the end of it
and no one out there in space the shiar
the dune the cree the scroll they're not
gonna care right because remember one of
the things we've always talked about is
as far as they're concerned humanity is
a pain in the ass and so it's kind of
nuts because when he goes to use the pen
stair and wong is basically ready to
meet his faith because there's really
nothing he can do bats possesses doctor
strange and so at that point doctor
strange is possessed by his own dog
which is kind of nuts but cool at the
same time he's like okay cool like
thumbs okay this is cool i can work with
thumbs thumbs are awesome right like
bass is just enamored by the fact that
he has thumbs he's like the things i can
do with thumbs
it's pretty amazing it's pretty cool but
what it does is it removes doctor
strange from the equation it kind of
evens the playing field a little bit and
then you basically switch over to mark
spector who in for a reason that's never
really clarified here and we're not even
really sure he was able to do it is able
to lift the hammer off of blade now
here's the thing what's really really
murky about this is we don't know if he
was able to do it because he's actually
worthy because immediately after that
happens the hammer is summoned by uh by
jane foster so did he lift it as jane
foster was summoning the hammer or was
moon knight worthy to lift thor's hammer
let me know which one you guys think
right let me know if you guys think like
which one do you think it is do you
think he's worthy or do you think it
just kind of happened around the same
time i'm curious right but essentially
with the hammer out of the way right
like with blade able to kind of return
to his normal self blade steps up he
actually stabs thor in the face which is
kind of nuts
and then you basically have this kind of
plan that's implemented by wong right
this backup plan and it's sheer genius
the way that wong does this so while
everybody's fighting everybody else he
tells johnny blaze now's the time right
he and johnny blaze basically kind of
had to miss a meeting behind the scenes
and was like i'm going to ask you to
make a sacrifice and i need to know can
you do this right the price you will pay
for the sacrifice that you will make
will be eternal but i need to know if
you can do this and the response of
ghost rider was basically if it ends
mephisto sure right if it leads to the
defeat of mephisto it's a sacrifice i'm
willing to make and so what ends up
happening here is johnny blaze literally
takes off on his motorcycle and then
rides up hotel inferno right rides up
this building to the penthouse of
mephisto and goes to confront him with
the intention of destroying him at that
moment mephisto lifts the curse of the
ghost rider off of johnny blaze right so
johnny blaze is effectively mortal in
turn mephisto kicks him out of the
building and kills johnny blaze right
johnny blaze is essentially dead right
and he's just like and when when the
question is asked like why in the world
did mephis like when johnny blade's like
why why did you do that the response to
mephisto is for the hell of it right so
with johnny blaze dying his soul is
basically sent to hell because remember
he entered into a bargain with mephisto
and whenever you enter into a bargain
with mephisto your soul is taken to hell
right it's taken to the realm of
mephisto now at that point mephisto's
like okay cool we're done right this
fight's gone on long enough this whole
thing needs to end it's been slightly
entertaining but like he basically tells
all his henchmen he'll kill him right
kill the midnight suns be done with it
the problem is that when that happens
his soldiers attack him right like the
avengers attack mephisto and when the
question is like why that's when you get
the ruse wong is like okay so like i
couldn't tell any of you because the
risk was too great but this is the deal
that i made with johnny blaze with
johnny blaze basically being sent to
hell and with mephisto absent from his
throne it leaves the throne vacant that
someone can take it as long as you sit
on the throne of mephisto you will
obtain the role of being the ruler of
hell you will take the crown of hell and
because mephisto is away from his own
realm because he in effect quote unquote
abdicated the throne johnny blaise has
taken his place johnny blaise is now the
new leader of health just a ridiculously
just pull the rug out from under you
kind of situation i love it right so
those guys who are curious as to how it
was that johnny blaze became the the
lord of hell this is how it happened it
was a trick by mephisto it's using
mephisto's own motivations against him
it's the thing that mephisto never
considered if he sent johnny blaze to
hell but he himself wasn't in hell to
maintain his throne then what would
happen here right like what would end up
going on and so the response is is when
he's told that mephisto initially
refuses to believe it and he's like no
no no there's no way that's true but on
the off chance that it is let's go to
hell my friend let's go to hell wong and
let's find out if that's that's the case
right so he literally rips open a portal
they you know him and wong end up
descending into hell dr strange tries to
save wong where he can but ultimately he
just can't and wong ends up basically
falling down into the realm of hell but
instead of falling there and dying
because johnny blaze is the one who runs
it johnny blaze is like no no you're
good man you're cool right it's because
of you all this was possible in the
first place so in the end what you end
up getting is basically this kind of
knock down drag out fight between
mephisto and basically the rest of the
midnight suns along with doctor strange
the biggest issue here and what's
interesting is that wong really puts off
this idea and it feels like a kind of
unnecessary aspect of the story but wong
puts off this idea that for a long time
stephen strange kind of saw himself in
isolation right he saw himself as like
the sorcerer supreme but never really
saw himself as somebody that had the
ally of friends and so as a result right
now because the forces of the avengers
are still under the control of the lord
of hell which at the moment is johnny
blaze their souls still belong to him
those souls can be controlled and so the
response of wong is what steven strange
needs is to be reminded that he's not
alone that he's not fighting by himself
him resurrecting las vegas trying to
prove himself to the world that was him
trying to find something right trying to
find an aspect of himself that he felt
was lost he's like but show him that
he's not fighting on his own show him
that he's fighting with you is part of a
larger group and so basically what you
end up getting is johnny blaze
essentially taking the souls of the
avengers and then bonding them to doctor
strange which of course amps his power
and allows him to overcome mephisto
mephisto in turn is sent back to his own
realm of hell where johnny blaze awaits
him and the crazy thing here is that
once he's there basically what johnny
blaze has done is assembled everyone
who's ever been turned into a ghost
rider in the history of the universe by
mephisto and that because time passes
differently there a few hundred years in
health is only a few seconds on earth
basically mephisto spends a few years in
hell just getting just getting
absolutely beat up right getting
absolutely trashed something i also do
want to point out here people whenever
people think of of ghost rider when they
think of how ghost rider looks what
you're actually thinking of the person
you're actually thinking of is danny
ketch so looking at this image here the
guy with the crown on his head that's
johnny blaze but the guy to the left of
him with a chain across him that's danny
ketch right that's the one you're
thinking of so again in the front going
from left to right you've got danny
ketch you've got johnny blaze and then
you have robbie reyes the newest ghost
rider that exists out there but of
course following them basically
pummeling him they send him back to
earth with a note that says like go easy
on him right he's had a rough hundred
couple of years right the the thing
about this being if he stays in his own
realm for too long he'll basically seize
control of hell again so the only way to
basically keep mephisto out of the
picture is to keep him on earth because
the longer he's away from his realm the
weaker he becomes all the way to the
point where i imagine if he's away from
his realm long enough he's really no
more powerful than someone like captain
america or just some average person we
don't really know because we really
haven't had instances where mephisto's
been outside of his realm for like
months or years at a time he only ever
really shows up out of his realm for
like a few moments right for like maybe
a story arc or something like that and
then goes back and in fact he's made a
prisoner in his own hotel inferno he's
basically locked away hotel inferno
itself ends up becoming a massive
tourist attraction
literally everybody starts showing up
there it's like the most popular hotel
in all of las vegas and it makes sense i
don't know if you guys have been to
vegas vegas is amazing so long as you
don't go during the summer you should go
during like the late fall or like the
early spring winter's not a bad time but
like it's literally the middle of the
desert right like you're gonna freeze
it's either really hot or really cold
right it's never really in between it's
it's temperate right but like it's
really really cold and it gets it gets
cold in the winter time but having been
to vegas like three or four times myself
yeah man i would go to hotel inferno i
would check it out i mean do i need to
worry about my soul being taken to hell
no okay cool yeah let's go check it out
right it's like if there's like a
warning sign outside there that like
it's like warning upon entry your soul
will be taken to hell where it will be
tormented by a demigod looking to attain
control of earth by any means necessary
then yeah i probably wouldn't go in but
even then i mean if they were like but
like the ribs or bomb here i'd be like
maybe for like a couple minutes you know
it's just one of those things but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace